this week on the true journey podcast
it's the lineal
heavyweight champion of the world
aka the gypsy king
everybody wants to be a boxer today
doesn't it superstars rock stars
movie stars youtubers they don't want to
be fighters don't they there's something
some people work hard for stuff and get
there and enjoy it i don't know what
that
feels like because i'm always looking to
do something more
beating glitch go going to beat wilder
going to saudi arabian fighting bronze
roman
whatever i do that ain't enough i'm
always looking for more
i'm always looking to better that don't
make men like me anymore i'm dying
[Music]
the routine for me is having a normal
life i'm not getting carried away with
all the glitz and glamour and all the
[__] like i said i go from las vegas
back to malcolm topping the bills in las
vegas the changing shitty nap he's
immortal taking the [__] to the team
you'd be dana white's dream what would
it take for them to get you in the ufc
it wouldn't take a lot i've got three
fights left on my contract when they're
up i'm coming for every ufc heavyweight
there is
you can't teach me anything about boxing
no one can because what i don't know
about boxing ain't worth knowing
trainers
eat well and get your rest andy ruiz
let's just use him he's a great example
little fat pig
comes in on three weeks notice murdered
every donut and taco in the whole of
california and then goes in with a man
who's had a 12-week training camp with
every sports scientist in the united
kingdom but the little fat fella goes in
and bowls him over in seven rounds
how do all them scientists look at me
then and say this is better this is how
you should do it
because they can't
[Music]
as a fan of you there was like obviously
concerns after the last fight because
this guy gave you a real challenge to be
fair you really put it on you how do you
feel when you look back at that fight
now i loved it
loved every minute of it 47 stitches
what's that what's 47 stitches to a
[__] like me
from mommy
[Music]
this week on the true journey podcast
it's the lineal heavyweight champion of
the world
tyson fury i've wanted to say that for a
while i know right that's crazy but
you finally say it i feel like sounds
good can you say it again yeah
the lineal heavyweight champion
of the world aka the gypsy
that's it the gypsy and the geordie king
i'll take it i'm going to
i'm going to adopt that no i'm not too
sure like
am i allowed to swear on this podcast
because on mike tyson's podcast we go up
to some crazy
yeah yeah conversation we've got some of
that as well if you want no
you can do anything honestly okay just
saw no
you know yeah okay yeah exactly
suppose the burning question on
everyone's lips is are you getting
the christmas number one with robbie
williams is that being released very
soon yeah
um it's a very catchy song i enjoy it
everyone i will listen to it say it's a
good one so i'll let you listen to it in
a minute
oh really and exclusive oh brilliant
we've heard
i'm not on the podcast sure and uh we'll
see if you like it so it's going to be
exciting times robbie's a bit of a he
was a fan of this podcastic he was the
big
first celebrity i got on he's a lovely
guy did you get on well with him yeah
yeah he's a nice fella
he's a bit of a boxing fan as well he's
just taking it up he is yeah he's been
training with uh tony jeffries
right you know he's called out um one of
the lads from oasis he wants to like a
celebrity fight
like the youtubers see everybody wants
to be a boxer today
yeah is that weird from superstars rock
stars
movie stars youtubers they all want to
be fighters don't they there's something
in it
is that weird for you to see everyone
trying to follow in your footsteps no
not really i think it's fantastic for
boxing because you know you've got
very famous people wanting to be coming
to the game
um it only brings more profile to the
sport that i love
did you see the ksi logan fight i've
never seen it no
because i've seen you talk about a bit
beforehand you're quite supportive of it
which i thought was really nice yeah
listen
i support anyone who comes into boxing
you know it's uh it all brings more eyes
to the game
and the more eyes are on it makes it
better for the younger upcoming fighters
of the future
we've got your book here by the way if
you haven't already you have to check it
out everyone i've been reading it
it's really like from you it isn't it
doesn't feel like someone else has like
interpreted your story
we put a lot of time into that i started
writing that book before i started me
come back
right so when i first started writing
that book i was weighing 28 stone and
down and depressed as ever so
i think from the beginning of the book
you can tell that towards the end i'm
getting happier again yeah
so yeah it's uh is it is it streams
reading those thoughts back in your head
and seeing how differently you find
yourself thinking now
definitely like reading some of that
stuff in that book just thinking about
how i was back then to how i am now
total different person total different
mindset and what a difference a year can
make two years can make and
it's a dramatic turnaround dramatic
change yeah because i remember
in the build up to what was supposed to
be the klitschko rematch
you started saying things that fight i
should never say like i hope he knocks
me out
and i was like what what is this like
what is this
because i was very unwell at that time
yeah very very unwell
and at that time i didn't care if i
lived or died there's an interesting
story i was in training camp
uh in holland and i just i just didn't
care i was
sparring big heavyweights i was just
letting them punch me all about that i
won't even defend myself
stand there lmt off of me and then in
between rounds i go back and head bought
the corner posts
they was like what is this we've never
seen anything like this
i said i have a lunatic i was going mad
at him just letting him hit me
and uh yeah it was a tough time to go
through but you know
i wouldn't change a thing because it's a
part of me
and i wouldn't be the man i am today
without all that happening to me
with you you've got such a story i
almost don't know where to start but in
in terms of
um when you go back through the mental
health struggles that you've had
is there a a moment that stands out
early on where you feel like awareness
when
where you oh you look back and you see
times where it was creeping in and can
you pinpoint anything that sort of began
all this
i don't think it's something that just
triggers i think you've either got it or
you haven't right
i've struggled with mental health my
whole life but up until a few years ago
i never understood what it was
i just thought i was feeling down or
whatever and i used to have anxiety all
my life as well from being a little odd
i used to think like something was going
to happen and i'd be all anxious
but i didn't i didn't know what that
meant up until i've
become educated on the matter i had no
understanding or no clue
what mental health was i just thought it
was a feeling that i had
and that was it just like many other
people out there who have the same
feelings and don't understand it
i'm very grateful to you for speaking
out because uh being a big man myself
seeing a big man like you
i've had uh you know suicidal thoughts
anxiety that
impending doom like something's about to
go wrong the world's about and
you're just sitting there nothing's
happening and seeing you come out and
speak about it just gave me sort of a
bit of uh
a bit of courage like yeah this is all
right you can see stuff like this and
i've tried to do it myself so
thanks um but you know you've dealt with
it in a different way i feel like
um you spoke about like uh god and
religion and things like that that's
helped you through it
um but it sounds like this is a medical
thing as well so
what kind of things have you used to
battle this
i've used prayer and i've used training
really they were my medicines for
to come back basically i never started
back
training to to box again i never thought
i'd ever box again i didn't want to
at this time during that book being
wrote i didn't want to return i had no
interest in returning to boxing i hated
boxing
or although i fought because i was that
unwell
everything i held dear to my life and
everything i respected didn't mean
anything to me at that point
so i started back training to to get fit
again to lose weight
and while i was in the uh the routine of
training and all that i've
got well again and made a comeback
and got back into boxing but i never i
never did take any medicines or anything
like that
i think i took like two days of um of
medicines pills
while i was away and i was feeling very
unwell i took two days of pills and i
thought this is not for me because
like me i've got an addictive
personality and
i didn't want to be addicted to
medication my whole life but my advice
would be to anyone who's suffering or
anyone who's got a problem
the sooner you see the doctors the
sooner you can get well again
you've got to admit it first and then
you've got to seek medical advice
to get well again i found like talking
to people to be like a really good uh
sort of
with therapy even if it's just your best
mate or family members
who was it who you sort of talked and
confided in
it wasn't a matter of me talking to one
individual i was talking to millions of
people
during my full struggle i was very open
i was doing videos all the time
i was doing videos when i was down
videos when i was up videos all the time
and
i was talking to everybody at that time
i was trying to get well again
and inspire others at the same time so
it was a difficult journey for me
um but what else really helped me
through was
setting short-term goals and having a
routine a structured routine in my life
um and that's how i got through it
without that routine without routine in
my life
if i have three days where i've got
nothing scheduled and i don't go to the
gym
i'll be as down as i can ever go again
it's like people say oh you've defeated
mental health no i haven't
but i've learned to maintain and manage
mental health and
people are saying now always a gym
junkie he can't leave the gym alone
well that's true i can't leave it alone
because i don't want to go back to
the hotel california again i want to be
in the real world and living a normal
life
so that's why i go to the gym so often
do you think you do live a normal life
yeah
do you think it's would you consider
your life to be a normal
everyday life the same as everyone else
yeah 100 yeah i do now anyway
yeah i didn't before yeah because it
definitely was far from a normal life at
that point yeah listen
when you're very unwell nothing's a
normal life but when you're thinking
straight and you're in a well-mind and
you can go back to reality and just get
on with your life what did you
what do you um get from prayer because i
know there are so many people that sort
of um
say that's such an important part of
their life listen i i've all i've grown
up around it
so to me it's a normal thing i pray
every day and every night and that's it
but
you know the thing is with religion it
divides so many opinions
so it's something that i've learned to
keep my own business to my own self
right do you know what i mean yeah
because you might say oh yeah
that there were player religion health
people but then i'll have another
20 people say oh no that's wrong and
another 20 say yeah that's okay
so there's so many opinions and so many
people that you can upset
just by sharing stuff so you know
i don't really even want to go into it
my relationship with god is a personal
relationship
and it's none of anybody else's business
at all and that's kind of similar to
mental health in a way that everyone's
mental health is quite specific to them
100 and what works for me doesn't
necessarily mean it'll work for you
you or you yeah but there are elements
which are similar in everyone's they
need
that routine really helps the routine on
the short term goals
definitely work you know do you feel
like boxing is that routine part of that
routine
no boxing has nothing to do with it it's
almost two separate things
yeah right the routine for me is having
a normal life
and not getting carried away with all
the glitz and glamour and all the
[__]
yeah because it's all very unimportant
and you should never get carried away in
it
i'll never lose yourself or lose the
fact to what you stand for and who you
really are
and it's very easy to do that and get
caught up in all rubbish
but at the end of the day when it's all
over you're just another bare bum in the
shower and nobody wants to know you
what was the relationship yeah i love it
i love how honest
you are was it impact it was impacting
the relationship with the people around
you at the time as well
how was it impacting your relationships
with yeah i think it was terrible i was
on the rocks
listen when you're when you're thinking
about killing yourself every day
and there's nothing more that you want
in your life than to die you're in a
terrible place
and it affects negative i was so
negative all the time and
i could be around people and make them
negative so
it's very important for me not to be
around negativity because
one of them people who can be brought
down very quick and i don't want it you
know
i used to worry about a lot of stuff in
my life worry about what people think
worry about
making people happy worrying about x y
and z
now i don't i worry about being happy
now and being happy today and tomorrow
and i don't walk past that because when
i start looking to the future which
we're not promised
only recently what i say has been backed
up my uncle went for a sunday dinner on
the way there he had art and i can die
at side the road
so that's how we're not promised
tomorrow so i live today
because i know that i am not guaranteed
to wake up in the morning
so i'm just going to be happy for now
and that's how i live one day at a time
if i go to bed sad tonight i think to
myself you know what tomorrow's going to
be a brand new day
i'm going to wake up happy i'm going to
be positive and i'm going to crack on
i'm not going to worry about anything
because nothing's going to worry about
me
and i've i've got that through facts of
my life what's happened experiences
you seem so mentally strong yeah and
after
you're going so low and coming back like
that it's interesting that you still
admit that you still have those
battles on a daily basis but you you
overcome them with that structure
all the time i get up and downs you know
you can't you never escape
it i've said this quite a lot we're
going to use it again i liken mental
health
to a famous song that the eagles wrote
called hotel california as a person
there
you can check out any time you want but
you can never leave
and that's mental health you can check
out any time you want but guarantee
you'll always go back at some point or
the other
for sure it's a long hard battle and it
continues forever
but it can be maintained doesn't all
have to be gloom and doom it doesn't
have to be sad it doesn't have to be
painful
it can be maintained and managed with
the right structure in the right program
in your boxing did did the mental health
um ever affect your performance like
performance anxieties did did you ever
find that
like tyson fury as a boxer and tyson
fury as a human being
it's like um superman when he's clark
canton superman it's
two different people so tyson fury the
gypsy king
was never affected in boxing matches if
that makes sense
like i could be totally depressed and
down but when i go into a boxing ring
superman returns it's a different person
it's like almost a different character
if that makes sense yeah
totally there's two people there there's
tyson fury husband father and son
and there's tyson fury a boxing man who
who fights all over the world and does
whatever
like i said they go from las vegas back
to morkum topping the bills in las vegas
to changing [__] up he's immortal
taking the [__] to the tip
did
but you enjoy there is an element of
enjoying being a dad and going back
nothing can compare with it you know
like i said
getting carried away with all that glitz
and glamour topping the bills and the
biggest venues and
the biggest fights in the world in las
vegas where all dreams are made of
and come true and all that sort of stuff
then going home and going back to
reality school runs coffees in the
morning gym
five kids to attend to you know it's
it's a total different
uh turn of events
was the vegas lifestyle partly how you
ended up losing
control at one point do you think no
it wasn't um i'll tell you how
i had the breakdown and it's very simple
for someone who understands mental
health it's very very simple
what happened to me i suffered with
mental health me all for all life
but always put it to the back of the
queue back of the mind because i always
had a goal of becoming everywhere
champion of the world
nothing was ever going to stop me from
beating vladimir klitschko
in 28th november 2015. that was my be
all and end all of my life nothing else
mattered that was it
not whatever happened to me in my life i
had a lot of bad traumas happen
on the build up to that but i put it all
to the back of my mind i didn't want to
think about it because i didn't have
time
i had a i had a goal i had a burning
desire
to achieve greatness and i always had
that goal to concentrate on i always had
it there to say nope
i'm not going to get brought down by
that because i've got to do this
and going into that fight i was almost
afraid to win
because i knew for a fact i didn't have
a goal anymore after that
so that i almost i knew beforehand i was
going to go downhill
from there because when you set your
life
life to doing something you said you
stalled to beat a certain person and
become everywhere champion of the world
you get there then what
it's like you work all them years i work
from being 14
to 28 years old to becoming heavyweight
champion of the world and then i arrived
i thought to myself is that it what now
and i knew it was going to be disaster
because i never had a goal anymore
the devil makes work for idle hands i
never had that goal and never the drive
and ever the purpose in life
when you've had a purpose my all sole
purpose forever i'd been boxing and
training and boxing and fighting to the
top
but when i arrived it was like i don't
have any further i can go now that's it
my life's over
that was the attitude i had i said to i
said to the
guys in the gym and said to me uncle
peter i said to the
christian trump conditioning guy said oh
what are you going to do when you win us
i'll tell you what i'm going to do
be down and depressed for about two
years after the fight
what 100 i said to paris after i got
back to the room that night
after being glitched go i got on my
knees and i thanked god for about half
an hour
and after i was finished doing that it
was late because i got drug tested and
press conference and all i was about
four in the morning and she said what
now so that's it
i said enjoy this while you can i said
because it goes downhill from here there
ain't no more further you can go from
this
this is it all downhill for me and she
was like what do you mean before i went
to germany we all had a little
meet up maybe daddy brothers and they
said oh
when you win this fight what are you
going to do i say i'm not going to box
again
i won't box again why you worked all
your life to get to this point
because that was it i knew what was
coming and i couldn't stop it
there's an emptiness sometimes when you
reach goals that is so irritating i find
like and
because i'm someone i feel like i'm a
pleasure seeking um someone who
constantly needs to be chasing something
down
and i'm so annoyed at myself sometimes
when i do hit a goal
and i just feel like deflated afterwards
and it's such a like what's wrong with
me like why can't i just enjoy
this that's me as well so frustrating no
matter what i've ever done in my life
what i've achieved
where i've been i've always felt
deflated after a
a good achievement not once have i ever
enjoyed an achievement i've worked hard
for
ever is that why you you've achieved
greatness though as well because
you don't find the same thing satisfying
that an average man would
well we all find the same thing
satisfying no matter who we are what we
are we cannot do the same thing we can
go out for a drink
get cyclists drunk we can go to the for
something to eat what else is there what
else can a human do on this earth
we can eat drink and sleep and what any
order you want to do
in that's it basically that's it
so everyone has the same enjoyments
but it's some people work hard for stuff
and get there and enjoy it but i don't
know that i don't know what that
feels like to enjoy a certain aspect of
hard work
because i'm always looking to do
something more that's never enough for
me
like beating klitschko going to beat
wilder going to
saudi arabia and find brunch roman
whatever i do that ain't enough
i'm always looking to for more i'm
always looking to better that
and there's just some things in life
that can never be bettered and i
understand that
do you see that as a gift or as a curse
sometimes it's a gift and a curse
right because it gives me a a steely
attitude where
nothing's gonna gonna set me off from my
goals but then when i get there it's
like okay
i've done that that seemed possible done
what next whatever else can i achieve
now
but it comes to a point in life where
when is enough enough
people say to me oh you've got three
fights left on your contract what are
you going to do then sign another
contract of a 10-year deal why would i
want to
what more can i do as a man as a person
as a human being as a boxer as an
entertainer
as a singer as an author now what more
can i do philanthropist
my goal now is just to be happy i've
achieved
i've achieved more than i ever thought
that was ever possible in life
and more and i know that
all the achievements in the world really
unimportant because you come in the
world with nothing and you'll definitely
leave with nothing
that's for sure just here filling voids
filling gaps
so does legacy not mean as much as it
used to do legacy has never meant
anything to me
not once even before i beat klitschko
said none of them belts
none of defending belt 20 times and
whatever mean anything to me
i'm cut from a different cloth i'm a
different breed to most
they don't make men like me anymore i'm
a dying breed
and that's it what uh what alls i want
is to be happy
and that's it and whatever it takes to
to find happiness that's what i will go
to
and i've been to hell i'm back and i'm
prepared to go to hell i'm back again
to get happiness you know when you say
they don't make men like you anymore
as an old-school bloke what do you think
about modern society
in the way of 10 do you have a feeling
about it generally do you know what i
have no feeling towards it really and i
have no
i have no negativity no positivity it's
just it is what it is
i just let everyone crack on with their
own business like i said for me
to go around thinking about all the
things and get me getting involved in
stuff that don't concern me
no real interest in it the only thing
i'm interested in
is being happy making me self happy and
knows around me and spreading positivity
and trying to help as many people as i
can
while i can what makes you happiest what
makes me happiest yeah
going to the gym okay i'm working out
yeah
like i got up this morning 6 a.m went
for a run in the rain
pissing down it was but i'm not gonna
miss that because that makes me happy
then i come back got the kids up for
school took them to the school
and i went here and grabbed the train
and come straight here so
being routined and being fit you can't
you can't be anything better
than in shape and fit and if they said
to me right you could have a billion
dollars
but go back to where you were two years
ago or you can be a skint man on the
street living in a tent
but you're going to be fit and healthy
mentally well out of that one place
a billion dollars and where you were a
few years ago would be a bad combination
as well
is all that money to spend it but what
you're going to spend it on
yeah like i said you can only do the
same thing go to the pub
go to the pub and you can buy a lot of
drinks for under a quid can't you yeah
is that why you donated the deontay
wilder purse because
it was a it was a sign of to show
everyone else what you are truly about
no and i don't i don't do things for
pats on the back
i don't do anything i don't whatever i
do with my own money
and whatever i do for charities i don't
do it for publicity that's why you never
hear about it
yeah i'm not interested in becoming a
do-gooder
or a jobs worth oh look at tyson he
thinks he's a top bloke because he's a
he's helped a woman across the street or
he's give the shoes off his feet to a
man
i don't want praise from a norm from
people do you know what i mean
i don't do stuff i don't help other
people for credit
i don't care if anyone knows about it or
they don't it's one of them things you
know
it's something that i'm not bothered
about praise at all
is that because in the past you've had
both
massive criticism and massive praise
that you treat those the same now you're
just like
look i am who i am have you learned to
live with whatever
you know i don't have any hard feelings
towards anybody or any listen people can
say what they want about me no interest
they're not people saying stuff about me
it's all sticks and stones in it we
learn about it in primary school
and that's it even when you were
depressed though because for me when i'm
feeling down
and i'll work on social media and when
you're getting it constantly
it can make things a little worse were
you good at just blocking that out even
when you
don't i don't go on social media i don't
i put what i need to put out there
up like so like instagram posts on
twitter's tweets or whatever
but i don't read replies i don't answer
messages i don't
look at the indirects i only put out
it's only
to me it's not personal i don't need to
have a virtual reality life online
people i care about i can see him face
to face or phone them on the phone
hello goodbye bang i don't need to go
online i'm not looking to make any new
friends
i ain't looking to get this virtual
reality lifestyle i have no interest in
what's going on
online so it's what i do is i put my
stuff out on
social media and that's it i don't read
comments i have no interest
as long as i can do what i need to do to
promote me fights or whatever i do on
there whatever it's used for
that's what i use it for they're not
personal sites
they're not like full of family pictures
and following loads of people
interests that i am interested in if you
look at me social media it's got 11
i follow 11 people or whatever but it's
all to do with what what i do like the
boxing or whatever
i don't i'm interested in cars and
classic cars and pidgey clay pigeon
shooting and
off-roading and defenders and stuff like
that but that's not on there because
it's that's personal to me
what is your favorite car favorite car
probably a land rover defender
really yeah i even know i can't fit in
them on their uncomfortable thing
but it's more of an iconic british motor
and i do like looking at them yeah
that's why i've got a few of them
they're not the most beautiful car but
i like it i like the fact that they like
because they're quite practical
i bet you uh do you use them quite a bit
not really i just look at them they're
toys to me
you know this book i'm just wondering
what made you call it behind the mask it
sounds quite
self-explanatory yeah because like i
said the two characters i've played
people can read that now and see the
real me yeah
since i come back two years ago for
whenever i come back june 18
i've not had a mask on i've not been
being a performing monkey as i used to
call myself
yeah i've just been being me and
people either like that or they don't
and i'm not selling stuff for promoters
anymore
if they if they ain't got the ability to
sell their own shows
then they're not worth being with before
i was selling these shows i was out
there i was grinding i was selling every
day
i was trying to get people interested i
was doing this i was doing that
now the promoters do their own job
that's what they get paid for
so up before i was doing everybody's
jobs now i'm not i'm just doing my own
you've broke through haven't you become
that mainstream
household name are you proud of yourself
for that or do you not care
again it's not really of a concern yeah
you seem to be really enjoying it the
wwe by the way
i did enjoy it yeah it was very fun and
it was a it was a lifetime ambition
achieved
yeah did you watch it when you were a
kid as well yeah i grew up watching
it who were your favorites bret hart
triple h
shaw michaels the rock undertaker stone
cold
mankind kane similar eras that i think
we
yeah we grew up with on the city i'm uh
which one did you meet like uh which one
was your favorite that you met in person
i met i met
them all all the old timers all over
hogan ric fleur
rick was a was a real uh
good man to go out and have a beer with
a bit i had a beer with him in
las vegas and he was a character for
sure 70 year old but definitely a
character
do you think they were in all of you a
little bit because you are i know
they're performers but you're a real
fighter do you know what i mean
i think it's it's mutual right i think
they're a bit inaudible
like for me grew up watching these
people on tv and like then uh
i'm there having a beer in las vegas
with them it's almost like fairy tale
stories
yeah whoever thought that i'd be over
there with them people and
shaking all hogan's hand and him coming
to wish me luck for the fight and all
that
it was it was a dream come true ironic
because obviously mike tyson
went to the wwe as well and you're
following in his footsteps crossing over
you had a re he had a massive wrestling
match with braun strowman who
he looks like a unit like he looks a
massive this guy
uh are you what was it like facing off
against him because although it is sort
of theatrical
he's a beast this guy yeah listen it was
no different to facing off against any
fighter i've ever faced off against
because when the 60 odd 70 000 people
screaming and shouting
and you're all up and your adrenaline's
pumping i believed i was going into a
battle like i always do
i said my little spartan chant before i
moved the gang and we went to war
and whatever happens and i didn't feel
any of it because the
adrenaline was pumping even when i got
slammed on the floor ain't a soft canvas
it's like that oh yeah but you just
don't feel it when you're in the mid to
battle
you don't feel getting punched in the
face and you don't feel anything when
you're in that mood
mindset you've mentioned is it brock
lesnar you fought quite fancy a fight
with
yeah i fancied the fight with brock for
sure yeah that'll be a big one wouldn't
it with him being a former ufc
heavyweight champion
uh did you watch us ufc fights at all
yeah
i watched a few of these flights for
sure pretty handy like pretty andy while
i could flatten him inside
is there anyone wwe match or in a proper
fight
i could flatten brock lesnar in 30
seconds i've i've seen you
training with daryn till shout out to
until what a legend he is
and you do look good with all the limbs
not just the boxing gloves like you
could do it big shout out
yeah do you know i've always been
interested in um
in fight that's what i've been born and
bred at it's what we come from
fighting is in our blood um on whether
whatever type of fighting it is whether
it's boxing kickboxing mma wrestling
whatever it is
it's all like contact sport isn't it i
think i'm athletic enough to do any
any fight sport for sure no matter what
it is and i've got the right mentality
where
yes i can do anything i want to and
nobody can tell me oh it's too dangerous
or
you're going to get your arm broke or
whatever if i
when i set my mind up doing a fight
sport then i do it
i've seen front mirror offered to help
you we've had frank miron before
who better he's a former heavyweight
champion yeah and the jujitsu that he
could like pass on so that
if you are on the ground any point you
know what do get yourself over
i mean you'd be dana white's dream yeah
that would be
can you imagine right i sign a a fight
to fight stephen
their heavyweight champion and we have a
we have a crossover
because that would be bigger in my
opinion
it certainly would be better than
mayweather mcgregor
because we'd we'd really be getting a
true fight there
it would i felt like mayweather just
nullified mcgregor and we didn't get
what we'd hope
for exactly if he come into a boxing
ring
on the boxing rules it'd be ten times
worse than
um mcgregor made because at least
mcgregor knows how to box
and he's grew up around boxing and jim's
in double in the or box
everybody in dublin can box there's
about a million gyms there
yeah so steeper he can't box it won't be
a boxing contest
but in that world i i'd be intrigued to
see if he could take what i could put
out for sure
then four rounds gloves would be so very
different wouldn't they would you be
confident or despite because people like
ingarnu have called you out and that guy
he's got that one shot kill power um
and obviously you've taken a hell of a
lot of punches taking the hardest
punches of all time even
would you want to go ahead and do it
with him yeah because i look at francis
senganu
and stipe makovich they're like six
round bill fillers if they were boxers
they wouldn't even win a a central area
title all right so they can't box
they're just like brawlers
so i've been hit by the biggest punches
in heavyweight history beyonce wild
they're all knockouts exactly dr steel
armor 60 odd knockouts
and i'm still here telling the story so
if i can't beat a six round bill filler
as he's got the striking force of a
middleweight
it's different it's different games but
listen their game ain't to go standing
up with me
i'm punching because there's only one
winner and me with them foreign take me
to the floor
so if i put the time and effort into
not getting tucked to the floor then i
believe i can chin him just like raymer
did with tim sylvia
and i i actually believe you could do
that because you've got that um
your hips are quite quick like you move
fast and
you see big guys uh like travis brown
who married
ronda rousey he's got your build and he
managed to learn it very quickly as well
because he's similar
light on his feet type guy well the the
stand up side of it the boxing and the
kicking and all that
i'm quite good with oh yeah because i've
trained for kickboxing as well
but like obviously going down on the jiu
jitsu side of it it's a different world
doesn't it
yeah we've seen tony um who's the guy
fought randy couture
james tony james tony that was right he
struggled as soon as he hit the deck
didn't he
james tony was one of them people who
one of the best boxers has ever been
yeah but like just does things for money
you know what i mean he probably didn't
even train for that
yeah the gut hanging over his trousers
and it was what it was
it wasn't uh it wasn't a vintage james
tony to be fair
we we see conor mcgregor offered a tree
in you as well i mean that it couldn't
get any better than that you two
together that's a dream
jesus the press conference you really
think you would do it
like because there's you you mentioned
you'd you'd be up for it but obviously a
lot of the boxing fans are praying that
you wouldn't leave boxing
what would it take for them to get you
in a ufc it wouldn't take a lot i've got
three fights left on my contract when
they're up i'm coming for every ufc
heavyweight there is
there you go then um and who is it
deontay wilder next
deontay wilderness february 22nd are you
confident he gets past ortiz and there's
no issues there
you can't be confident in heavyweight
boxing because it only takes one punch
to get knocked out as we've seen many
times
but you'd have to be confident ortiz has
got to be a minimum of 48 to 49 years
old
i love how we're guessing it's got to be
it's crazy isn't it so
he's a dangerous customer for four or
five rounds
if not the most dangerous one of the
most dangerous heavyweights in the world
for four rounds because even when you're
old like that you never lose your power
as we saw with george foreman when he
knocked out michael mora he was 45 and
he still chinned
the young maura who who stopped
holyfield in his prime
so yeah you never lose your power but
you'd have to fancy the younger
more active more match fit wilder how
how would you see that
rematch going with wild after the last
time because i felt like you should have
won the decision as many yeah
i think everybody in the world apart
from deontay wilder's family ford
identified
and not judge andre rasheen
and where he come from whatever um
yeah it was what it was but it was
expected because
i went over to their show i boxed on his
own show his own promotion
in his own country so it was pretty much
expected you'd be yeah shafted then yeah
do you see that said i wouldn't get the
decision out there before i left
but it's different now because they've
got come to me
because now i'm the kingpin of america
and um they've got to come to me and and
work on my terms
where before it was all on their terms i
was going to challenge deontay wilder
deante wilder's got to come and
challenge me and is that
is that contract signed is that
definitely okay
it was signed before i fought walling
right okay
then you were signed everything's done
as a fan of you there was like obviously
concerns after the last fight because
um the fight beforehand i mean i think
that might be one of the best i've ever
seen you
like untouchable and then this fight uh
this guy gives you a real challenge to
be fair you really
put it on you and you showed that great
championship determination to get the
win
but um people were concerned your dad
was concerned um
talks about should your coach stay on
how do you feel when you look back at
that fight now
i loved it loved every minute of it 47
stitches what's that
what's 47 stitches to a [__]
like me from mommy
nothing you look funny i'm not a gypsy
warrior what's a [__] gonna do me or a
few pounds of blood pissing out
everywhere
ain't nothing i gotta caught big deal
get over it
it is what it is you can't go swimming
and not get wet second cut in 11 years
as a professional boxer ain't too shabby
i loved it it was it proper good for me
because
i wanted the drama it was mexican
independence day i wanted blood and snot
all over that ring and the fans got what
they wanted
it was a great fight fought with one eye
for like nine rounds
got caught in the third and one on to
the 12th bowed it out
it was what it was it was lovely i
enjoyed it i thought it was a great
performance
ben said to me how do you feel about
round seven i said i live for this [__]
i see that this is what i live for
and i'm happy i was happy happy i got
caught bear for screw loose but whatever
you know it was a good 12-round fight
and it put me in good stead for the
while to fight is that when you feel
most alive
when when you're being challenged and
pushed yeah it wasn't really a challenge
it was only a cut
he um he was just getting battered every
round
he could take a good idea yeah you know
he was a viking wasn't he from
denmark or one of them countries sweden
so yeah they're going to be tough men
aren't they if you ever want to pick a
fight with someone make sure it's a
viking because they'll definitely fight
back
um so you feel like the adjustments will
be made for the dionne weather fight
that
there will be tweaks made from because
people were talking about did you come
in heavy enough
et cetera et cetera would you change
anything for the other fight
from you i don't i don't train for a
weight anymore really whatever i weigh
in at hawaii now
it's like whatever i go in on the night
i'm not dieting i'm already on me weight
whatever i weigh away i'm not trying to
lose weight or put it on
years ago i would lose five or six
stones to fight people
yeah but now i walk around and what a
box at so yeah i go into training camp
train couple of times a day
eat eat well eat plenty and whatever i
weigh away when you gained all that
weight i mean how
what was your heaviest weight just under
28 stone
jesus you've never even been that my
heaviest was 25
so that says a lot that's heavy though
oh yeah yeah
try getting them halfway around the
world it's difficult going away
you lost about three stone in two days
it was amazing you don't fit in the
seats dude no i made a nightmare i'm
sure you know especially in economy um
what were you like what was your
lifestyle like in terms of what were you
eating day-to-day was it just like
big food all the time no i'm not a big
eater i
wasn't then and i'm still not today it
was more like alcohol
right pints of beer i'd go out and have
like i don't know 15 16 points
on a night out like no problem yeah then
i'm going off like a load of pizzas and
stuff afterwards
eating junk food chocolates and sweets
and stuff but when you do that for two
years
and your body's used to training every
day to get them calories off
it just keeps going on and on i believe
i wouldn't be alive today anyway that's
for sure
but if i was then i'd probably be about
39 stone
you'd be on jerry springer sort of help
help me jerry yes someone cut on the
side of his house
just to get we've seen you in the
england shirt you're partying with all
the england fans like
you look like you're having a great time
obviously internally there was a lot
going on but
like do you really love drinking or is
it just a social thing you do it for a
laugh i like it as much as anybody else
who doesn't like to go out with the boys
and have a few beers
yeah so you haven't cut it out
completely now oh i was out when we did
on sunday we've got legless
good effect what's your favorite drink
peroni peroni it's quite sippable isn't
it it goes downhill oh draft though
draft peroni not the balls i'm not keen
on the bottles for some reason
they do taste different it's like it's
got to be ice cold and it's not served
in a prony glass so there's a problem
do you pay for drinks anywhere you go
now i don't mean that you're cheap i
mean everyone just goes
tyson let me get you a drink let me get
your drink i don't go out i don't go out
in public that often
right it won't go just to like some
random place for drinks yeah because i
get tortured
is the fame thing that's something that
you sort of you're not interested in
yeah practically the reason why
i i live in morkum because it's out the
way
and everybody who lives there has seen
me for the last 10 11 years
and yeah there's not much going on there
so it doesn't attract a lot of people
you don't get that reaction
as much do you feel at home there yeah
yeah i've been there 11 years and i uh
i do like it there every day i wake up
and say you know what i feel like i'm
going to move
me back to where like the manchester way
but i always
come up with a reason why i should stay
so i think it's the place for me
do you think you have quite um a
peaceful set of people around you as
well what about
yeah i don't have many friends i've got
as close-knit
um friendships for a few people and i'll
say i don't i don't see
i don't see that many uh
new people only when i go out and about
and stuff like that obviously i'm
meeting millions of people
but like yeah i have the same friends
now as when i started basically ten
years ago
in traveling do you think uh it's they
say travel broadens the mind do you
think it's broadened your mind
i think so yeah i think if you're stuck
in a room all your life you don't
know what's going on in the world and
you don't know what it's like they say
if you haven't had it you don't miss it
that's so true if you don't know what
what it's like to experience other
things then
you won't miss it that's for sure you
get stuck in your ways and that's it
but traveling around doesn't help and
it's a wonderful thing to be able to
to travel to different countries and and
experience different cultures and
different ways are going on and all that
and it's it's really it's been good you
know lived i've lived a good life
for the last i don't know how many years
20 years
um 38 31 years old
you feel 20. it's pretty good yeah i
feel 60. i feel worn out really i mean
you've done a lot
yeah you know you're i don't know why
i'm picturing like where you live is
like
is it an estate with like lord of land
type thing no no
normal five bedroom house next door to
people and
nothing's flash or special just an
average family house
just normal i'm just imagining people uh
waiting
in 2014 and i'm still there now i just
imagine waking up in the morning and
just sort of coming
you know he's doing the dishes in the
windy morning tyson yeah it must be so
unusual to see that would be you putting
the bins out next door those kind of
things yeah it's like you don't expect
to see a linear everywhere chamber of
the world just like
roaming around doing normal things
that's what your neighbors all say they
all go there goes the millennial
heavyweight jumping into the world mo in
the grass
him as he walks past the house all right
the only problem with my house is it
doesn't have enough land for what i want
right if i had like an acre or half an
acre more
then i don't think i'll ever move can
you clay pigeon shoot there or do you
have to go somewhere else to do that
well yeah well for clay pigeon shooter
clay pigeon shooting into the sea yeah
yeah it's uh
no you can't play pitch and shoot there
literally don't i don't have anyone
there
about as big as this this room in here
space for parking stuff
wow okay that's it okay a couple of
defenders basically
one of my favorite bits of the boot was
when you talked about your wife paris
yeah and um how you met and it seemed
very like uh
although you admitted you had your ups
and downs quite perfect it was
the story with me in paris it's like it
was meant to be because we lived hundred
mile apart
didn't know her from adam and then we
met each other on the off
and that was it we never we've been
together ever since and even before i
was going out with paris
i said to my dad i said i found this
girl and i'm going to marry him and dad
said well
i was about 16 what a god and i said i
found this girl
i said i'm going to marry her yeah said
well he said hey are you going out is
your girlfriend said no
not yet but i will do and i did the
conversations early on
she seems to have a very good way of
thinking that it would line up with the
way you think i could imagine
but was it always like that did you just
click straight off
yeah we did click straight away and
behind every good man as a better woman
yeah
if i didn't have paris i wouldn't be the
man i am today i won't be in this
position
i've probably been partying somewhere in
miami with a load of um
women and men and getting drunk every
day and living the high life but
i think having wife and kids grounds you
because you've got responsibilities you
can't just run around doing all that
stuff
and she's actually a pretty good boxing
pundit by the way like when coogan
interviews are
i'm like she knows a lot you know what
it's like i say to audrey this i say oh
you won't know this but she was i've
been around box for 11 years and i said
maybe she's going chair
he's from there blah blah blah said that
when he was like okay genuinely she
really does but how is she not gonna
also we ever talk about ole miss boxing
dad comes with the boys or my friends
yeah all they want to do is put boxing
on our watch fights and talk about
boxing so
she's there she hears it all and she's
been around a long time so she does
understand it
i was only speaking to her a couple of
days ago and
it's come to the point where she don't
want me to box
really she don't see the need in it we
don't need to box on
and it frightens very frightening for
her like even against
the last two opponents and even the
comeback and the wilder fight
she feels sick now she feels ill
watching and she don't want me to do it
how do you handle that as a husband it's
me job isn't it so
i must continue and it's not going to
happen forever
and that's it we will move on but with
all the tragedies that's been happening
you've got you've got to think of it
here as well like when is enough enough
well you say it's your job but it isn't
like a normal job and i'm sure she'll be
aware of
when they're dangerous do you need to
carry on financially is it is it your
job or is this
are you now doing it for your job
anymore yeah
when i first started in boxing my goal
and ambition was to
to buy my own house our boxing mm-hmm
and i thought if i could do that there's
been a lot of boxes in the past i've
i've trained them dedicated life and
they don't ever have anything out of it
so i thought i want to start if i can
just do that
then i'll be happy but then it was a job
now it's gone from a job to an obsession
and when you've got that box in bug you
can never get rid of it
actually it's funny because uh though
those two youtube lots i actually know
both for them and i've actually
like said on a recent video i think they
should just like finish now like you've
got the money
you don't get knocked out great let's
leave it at that um
but i'm not their wife so they're not
gonna listen to me as much as you'd love
to be
you're not their wife um what's tyson
fury the dad like what are you
are you old school and your dad
approaches as well or do you do you see
yourself becoming a bit more
you know new school sometimes like what
yeah i don't know like i suppose
you know the old school era you imagine
quite a disciplinarian or are you a bit
more leave that of the mother
for sure really yeah you've got that in
your eyes you can sort of tell do you
know what i mean
it's like i don't want to spoil the kids
because i think it has an effect on them
when they grow up
right yeah i want them to be their own
independent people get their own jobs
and do their own thing and have dreams
and ambitions of their own
so yeah i don't want to spoil them too
much but it's hard isn't it it's hard to
to not how are you going to treat people
who you love and who you've bred
and not want to give him everything and
do everything you can for them
so there's a there's got to be a an in
between somewhere
but yeah i try and do i try and be the
best that i can be
and that's i can't say anymore can i try
i try and take them places and do
when i'm at home do as many stuff as we
can as many activities as we can
together
and enjoy it and that's it do they get
to watch your box or
not not live they've been to one live
fight but they watch all the fights on
the tv yeah
i bet they're thrilled about wwe
thrilled yeah
yeah my son and daughter are big
wrestling fans really
they loved it if one of those wanted to
be a fighter one day how would you react
to that
each to their own if if that's what they
want to do then
let him do it my son you don't want to
be a boxer he wants to be a wrestler
really so yeah an mma fighter and a
wrestler
can't get enough of it so i'm not going
to discourage him
just going to let him see what he wants
to do with it if he wants to do that you
can my older daughter she wants to be a
dancer
so she goes to the dance school and
she's doing and i'm encouraging it so
hopefully that's your fault as a parent
i can only support them whatever they
want to do
i'm sure they're going to have a million
things that they want to do and let go
and let go and do this do that
it's all a part growing up isn't it have
you always had that then though that you
know obviously when you're a kid you're
picking all these things up will you
always
fight yeah there was nothing else i
wanted to be apart from a boxer
ever some kids they they try things and
don't do that football skating
wrestling boxing whatever i never did
anything else apart from
box did that feel natural to you yep it
felt natural
very dangerous it's interesting it's
interesting because i yeah you don't
meet many people who seem to have such a
clear path in life did that make you
more sure of what it was so clear that
your dad even called it practically from
birth wasn't it
he came out punjabi didn't he say we're
going to be having a chat in the world
from
was it from birth i mean that's clear
i mean as careers officers go that was a
good call
i believe that things are meant to be
though you believe in fate that's
interesting though yeah i believe in
fate and i believe in things are meant
to happen because
i was a newborn baby you can't you can't
say this child is going to be
heavyweight champion not unless he can
look forward 30 years
yeah but do you have tarot cards out by
any chance he must have done but
how is it possible that a newborn baby
was called after the heavyweight
champion of the world
and that newborn baby becomes
heavyweight champion of the world
what are those odds not gambling man
yeah but they'll have to be astronomical
odds
for sure you were premature as well
weren't you yeah so i'm
like quite severely premature as well
i'm not sure severely
seven weeks pretty much all yeah okay oh
well yeah to me that's still quite a lot
a lot i don't know i don't care
about it i don't i saw somebody had five
i'm not a midwife do you know what i
mean
i saw an article on the paper yesterday
front page born at 26 weeks
yeah so that's pretty much all yeah
extremely there yeah yeah so yeah
are you are you oh this is a mug i never
thought i'd ask this question but when
obviously when paris has had the
children have you been in the room where
that happened
yeah yeah what what do you like under
those other pressure situations oh
i love it yeah yeah you're excited
excited you're waiting on the new
arrival yeah
it's like the labor takes ages done it
sometimes it can take two days yeah
sometimes it can take
two hours who chooses the name yeah
mutually
we'll choose a name together sounds
quite nice yeah are you a bit of a
corner man
when you're uh and she's in there are
you kind of you know icing the face
yeah all those kind of things everything
yeah anything you can think of yeah
i'm even taking the gas and air for her
yeah
well this is good that's good
listen it's a family effort like i say
me and paris have been together from
being kids
yeah so there's nothing i don't know
about her and there's nothing she don't
know about me yeah
we're open books with each other there's
no secrets
that's rare these days as well i mean i
don't know anyone who
who got married so young and you're
still together all those years it just
doesn't happen
is there a trick to it that you feel
like you have got that people
haven't got these days it's not easy to
find someone as good looking as me
i don't know what it is you know what i
mean we've been together for a long time
we understand each other
practically all men are the same i
believe so you better probably with a
devil you know than one you don't
so that's probably got a little bit to
do with it as well um
and you know it's in our culture to
stick together as well
it's like she knows that like i just
said most men are the same anyway
so there's not much point in twitching
and choosing every 10 minutes when
something upsets you
and that's it that's just the way we are
do you argue like regular people we used
to do years ago
we don't we don't argue anymore really
that the the ingredients to
a happy life is a happy wife and how you
make your wife happy
is just say yes write it down lads if
you're listening
a happy wife equals a happy life i love
it
and now you make your wife happy three
three free letters yes yes that's it
and i believe when that wife's happy
the home's happy when the home's happy
everything stems from your home
so if i've got an upset home life then
that's going to affect me at work
it's going to affect me at my training
place it's going to affect me in
workplace it's going to affect me
everywhere
so it may be an old housewife's tale
happy wife is an happy life
but i i i believe it to be hundred
percent true because if ever i've got
like
arguments going on or upsetments in my
own home nothing ever goes right outside
of it you don't you don't think straight
you're not focusing on your job your
mind's elsewhere
if your mind's elsewhere you can't
concentrate 100 on what you've got to do
in life
do you have anyone in your life that um
you seem very self
self-motivated and self-driven and
obviously you're such a presence
that uh you know i've listened to other
interviews with you and a lot of those
people are almost uh
they skirt around things they don't feel
like they can challenge you almost do
you feel like there's anyone in your
life that can challenge you or sort of
go
tyson i think you're wrong on that do
you know what i mean yeah well i don't
have
i don't have things where i can be wrong
or right
right i don't get into debates with
people either yeah
it's like i've got a brother shane and
he's one of them people who's got to be
right everything he does
i'm right you're wrong and i've learned
the hard way because we've had a million
fights together
that challenging people on what they
think on their opinions
only leads to an argument right and it's
something that i'm not interested in
arguing over nothing so if someone says
oh this is right and i
even if i disagree i'll say yep that's
right and that sometimes upsets them
even more
but i don't want to challenge them yeah
some people just want
an argument or a fight yeah sometimes a
good argument is good though isn't it
sometimes you just need one
yeah but yeah i don't i don't challenge
people on anything they they think or
say
if it's right it's right okay who am i
to say it's not you know what i mean
it's one of them
fighting wise in paris we always have
like little bits and bobs like
she'll say this i'll say that she wants
to put me wrong whatever i'll do she
should have used the
cut on klitschko earlier yeah this is
over dinner and the kids are just
walking
like where but yeah we don't argue
anymore and i don't have anyone in my
life where
we argue with right i'm not one of them
people who oh it's my way or the highway
i'm open to do whatever if if we're all
going out we've all got suggestions of
what we're going to do today
it ain't just i do what i want to do i'm
like one of those people who'll go and
go with the flow if you want to go
wherever you want to go you want to do
what you want to do i'll come with you
ain't just my way like i'm the man you
follow me
because i'm i'm not into all that stuff
power trips on my own
immortality a lot of shite all my
friends and family
they don't treat me like i'm someone a
sporty man or whatever i'm just a normal
person to them
you seem actually quite opposite of your
fighting personality it's like
really opposite yeah it is it's almost
like a different person
yeah so laid back so chilled out
whatever you want to do i'm comfortable
with that yeah i'm not really bothered
if
say the only thing i ever do in life is
we go out for something to eat we take
the kids out somewhere
or we go to a boxing fight or a
wrestling event or whatever it is
so if anyone's got any other suggestions
that they want to do something i'm all
ears
i'm always up for new challenges and new
things to do yeah passing time away and
all that yeah so
i'm not i'm not caught up on my own own
uh
self is that the same when it comes to
boxing training as well because
obviously there are so many people
who've got so many different techniques
of you know we should train this way you
should we should do it that way is it
you who decides that or
what does that work basically people can
try and make a box invite into rocket
science and especially today like with
all this new technology and
all these people with university degrees
on sports science
they think they can implement that into
old-fashioned
fighting and it just doesn't work for
heavyweights
now i'm all for it when someone's making
a weight
and they're struggling then all this new
technology and new science stuff
really does work because one of my good
friends isaac lowe is a featherweight
and he always struggles with the weight
to get that last stone off
it's hard for him the last seven pound
and if they don't do that diet correct
then he struggles and it comes in his
performance but
heavyweight boxing is a different breed
different sport
to other boxing where there's no weight
categories
that it's a different world completely
and all those
scientists and all the things all this
new technology that comes out
i just don't believe it works for
heavyweights now i've got a strength and
conditioning guy
i've got a nutritionist and i've got a
trainer
and they all work together on things
they want to do and what i don't do and
all this and that
and i say to him look keep it very basic
none of the rest of the stuff works
there's three rules to boxing
train art eat well and get your rest
especially for heavyweights there's
nothing else because
when you want to start implementing all
these different technologies into your
game
improvements one percent here and there
it's a lot of shite to be honest with
you
andy ruiz let's just use him he's a
great example
little fat pig comes in on three weeks
notice
yeah murdered every donut and taco in
the whole of california
yeah and then goes in with man who's had
a 12-week training camp with every
sports scientist in the united kingdom
and whatever else he's done he's broke
every art monitor in sight
he's done every crossfit machine he's
done everything totally correct
and he's had the best nutrition and the
best diet you can get but the little fat
fella goes in and bowls him over in
seven rounds
how do all them scientists look at me
then and say this is better this is how
you should do it
because they can't because
it's still one-on-one combat
and anything can happen so do you think
aj is wasting his money
it's all mental he looks good it's all
in the mind he looks good on instagram
i believe like you can go all the people
and if you think and you believe
that they're going to improve you right
then they're probably
placebo yeah but i believe there's no
substitute for hard work
and dedication to the job and that's it
and now when when my nutritionist says
oh we want you to eat this starting over
i say no i'm going to have a mars bar
chocolate biscuit
and a cup of coffee with 10 sugars in
because it's not going to alter my
performance because i'm an heavyweight
and if you've got anything to say about
it go and wrote you andy joshua
do you take your time with 10 sugars
yeah i love the fact that this this
nutritionist is just made in this lobby
yeah the thing is though yeah
i don't eat salad and i don't eat veg at
all
no go areas but your skin looks great i
don't know how
kids if you like i don't eat salads and
i don't eat veg at all
to no extent why not do not like i just
don't like it is it in the jeans is that
a genetic thing
dad i mean daddy's all of it i don't
like it at all think it's viable i eat
it every day
yeah i can eat fruit
yeah when you're you're daddy you might
wish you could have done yes
never mind in 20 years what can happen
tomorrow
are you a meat eater do you like your
meat i like meat i like fish
i say i don't eat any veg i eat like i
can eat potatoes and sweet corn and peas
and stuff like that
sweet potato you can put gravy on yeah
we're good
yeah something you can make chips out of
i love it you two are so similar
do you know what andy ruiz you're on
about there this this rematch that's
happening very very soon i'm really
excited for this i feel like this is
the biggest test of aj's career how do
you see the rematch going
i see it going pretty much similar to
the first fight really
now i know that they've both lost some
weight and whatever they've had more
time to prepare and
they've changed a few things in the
training teams and camps and all that
i need a lot of different approaches and
they're going to try different game
plans
but mike tyson said it and it's very
true everyone's got a great game plan
until they get punched in the face
and it's so true you can be working on
something for ages and then you're
working it working at work and
you get tagged and that's it you go back
to how you once was and you want to
fight
and that's exactly what i say happening
because aj a lot of people forget that
but aj did drop ruiz first but
it was at that point that the real fight
started almost yes and true
and do you think that ruiz is just too
good of a technical boxer for him
i i don't believe he's too good at
anything because everywhere boxing
they're both big strong men and they
both can knock each other out as we've
seen
but what it is with me what my opinion
of that fight is
he beat him once and knocked him out so
he's got mental edge going into the
rematch for whatever excuse they made or
whatever the problem was in camp or in
the changing rooms or whatever
you're going into that mentally beaten
already
because you've already been knocked out
by somebody so
if we go outside now you knocked me out
yeah but i think
i'm i'm some big great boxing champion
and i get flattened yeah
then i've got to be thinking about that
going into the rematch of that but if
you say all right we want to fight you
again and i say oh okay then
just because i'm forced to i know in my
mind you've already chinned me
for whatever reason i try make or pause
i got the flu or
i wasn't looking at that time i wasn't
ready or whatever
i know you've already knocked me out so
the mental side of
i believe boxing is 95 in the mind
anyway
and 5 fitness and nutrition and all that
stuff
so yeah i think when when you've already
been beat by someone
and it wasn't like it was a lucky punch
that knocked him out like
you see linux lewis got knocked out by
rachman all over mccall
he was winning the fights and he got
chined that's it fair play every boxing
he come back and he he won him in the
rematch joshua wasn't winning that fight
i didn't give him i didn't give him i
may have given him one round out of the
seven he wasn't like is that the style
of ruiz that's just too much
uh too difficult for him do you think
everybody has a bogey mum right
in in the career and whether you find
him or not
everybody's got one really like i
remember when tony thompson knocked out
david price
and he tried to rematch him that was his
bogey money found him
lost twice um
i remember when tony thompson did it to
sully's as well the great cuban that was
going to be a world champion
found his bogeyman beat him twice and i
i i think personally he may be the
bogeyman for him who knows
but listen that's what boxing is that's
why it's an interesting fight
that's why we can all watch it whenever
it's december tune in
it's funny that um ruiz called you out
all like a lot of years ago
i think was on ifl actually and now we
might actually end up seeing that at
some point
do you how do you see yourself matching
up with ruiz because he has got an
awkward style
it's awkward style but he's tailor-made
for me he's six foot one or two
and squat leaning forward really
yeah that that style is easy for me was
that like the chazor
that's that style yeah is he any better
than derek gizora a good derek just saw
on a good night i don't think so
i'll handle that quite comfortably close
my eyes actually sometimes
when i'm behind me back and stuff like
that you know
that style is easy for me it's easy for
me to just jab and move
like klitschko would would make easy
work of him
ruiz because that style for him is easy
that that stature that that style he's
fought loads of them i followed
him all my career the average size
heavyweight is six foot one two three
seventeen eighteen stone and they swing
up some throw one twos
but it's the ones that are awkward and
gangly or
different style up that people struggle
with that the the conventional styles
are always easy to be
do you think you'll ever fight uh aj
depending on how he gets on in his
rematch i'd love that
i think would be fantastic for britain
it would be but it won't be in this
this contract because i i all my fights
are in america now yeah
so yeah it'd have to be after that if it
did ever happen but if he gets knocked
out twice in a row
i can't see him continuing to be fair
every man does what you want to do
but i think i think you think you would
retire well he doesn't need the money
and two knockout losses is a shattering
to you
to your career but it would be up to
them
whatever they do but i've got three
fights left so whoever them three fights
are
i don't really care to be fair line them
up whoever's the best at that time
let him fight me that's it and how do
you see your fight with uh wilder going
um by comparison the last time do you
think it could go the same way or be
honest with you it was an easy fight for
me last time
it wasn't even competitive in the boxing
side of it yeah the only thing good
about wilder is he's got a massive punch
and he can end the fight at any time
which we almost saw in round 12 and
round nine yeah
so yeah just more the same and just i'll
be much fit this time where i only had a
couple of fights last time and then the
big
the big lay off this time it will be
much fit ready
and we'll see yeah he seems to be making
a lot of excuses but that's the one
thing he never brings up is the fact
that you'd
were like 28 stone matter of much
he's not going to is he yeah because
again it's mental isn't it
boxing again he can't admit that i had
three year out the ring and come back
and and
fought him that doesn't come in he
thinks he fought the best tyson fury
ever
i can't get he said he said an interview
tyson fury can't get any better than
that but i can
but i don't know how i figured that out
because i just had free or out the ring
balloons tougher mental health problems
lost 10 stone
and two combat fights in six months and
jumped in with the best everybody out
there
so yeah obviously i'm afraid to fight
him
and you've been sort of working and
building this fight
into a much bigger fight in the rematch
do you think you're going to be
you're going to see much bigger numbers
now because the first fight and it's
going to actually all this planning's
going to come off
um i've not been considered or concerned
rather
considered i've not been concerned about
what beyonce wilder's doing and that
fight
i've just been continuing my boxing
career the two fights two boxing fights
i've had the wrestling match
just been enjoying my life i don't i
don't live other people's lives
they might be concerned of what i'm
doing or because i always see them
interviews and are mentioned to me or
stupid wrestling and all this that any
other and whatever but
you never see me talk about them no real
interest when the fights happen they
happen
and what they do in their own life in
their own careers is none of my business
at all there was a few people tweeting
from your fans point of view actually
saying
is tyson fury doing the right thing when
he's about to go and take on johnny
welder and he's taking on braun strowman
should he be do you will that affect you
in any way coming into a rematch
i won't think about deontay wilder until
i go into training camp in january
really yeah not i won't be thinking
about him
all year or whatever no interest it's a
boxing match yeah we're going to go in
there we're going to punch each other in
the face
and one of us are going to win or if if
the [__] happens again we have a draw
that'd be exciting wouldn't it two
drawers make it a trilogy you know
i don't i don't think about these guys
while i'm not not fighting them
it doesn't affect me i did see an
instagram post the other day directly to
him saying that you were going to do him
yeah only because he keeps he keeps
doing all um interviews and things
saying oh he's afraid to fight me
i don't know how we can say that when he
knows the contract signed anyway
it seems like you have um quite an
interesting relationship with your phone
uh like it's a it's really something
that's quite impulsive for you you can
kind of pick it up and you'll be like
right here i'm going in or i'm taking a
video of me dancing or i'm calling eddie
hernan
yeah we had eddie heard on the podcast
couple weeks ago he said you give him a
quick ring saying you should have signed
me instead of aj or something like that
or
just saying that you're going to destroy
aj you know what
eddie is a pratt i'm going to give him
no publicities really
fair enough yeah okay i didn't know that
so i didn't know you didn't get on with
him
yeah fair enough fair play do you um
you've got a question about boxing
training though because it seems like
when you brought
ben davison in that um i don't know like
when you're training a lot of it seems
to be more about getting fit than
learning
new boxing techniques you seem to feel
like you've got boxing
is that the way you train or do you
spend time out of the
when you're not in camp learning new
things no do i act
how are you gonna teach the linear level
champion one of the best boxers in
history
out of box if i couldn't box i won't be
where i am no i don't some people have
the attitude of always evolving
no i'm not i'm not evolving at all you
can't teach me anything about boxing
no one can because what i don't know
about boxing ain't worth knowing
that's true and what made you develop a
style that
people a lot of the time relate to
lighter weight boxes was that always a
it's just natural i'm not natural
athletic move and
all heavy weights walk forward and swing
big bombs so i thought to myself i'm
going to be different to the rest
going to use me footwork and and box
that's what it's about
but it's always been natural to me
boxing and moving and not a lot of big
men can do it and keep it up for
such long time like 12 rounds or not how
much of it is natural how much
because you are a heavyweight historian
how much of it is observed and stuff
that you think you've sort of picked up
down the years because you do seem to
weigh other men up very quickly when
you're talking about someone it doesn't
seem like you've sort of um
you've had to really study it seems like
you've just looked at him and gone and
you've taken it all in
yeah it's like when i've got these
fights coming up and however it may be
i know i don't need to study them
because i already know them
like being a historian i know what
stance stanciano australia
know how tall they are i know how many
fights they've had to know who they've
fought to know what the weakness are
know what their strengths are
so i don't need to watch them because
i'm very familiar with them um
if it was somebody i didn't know then
then obviously i'd do some work but it's
my job to know everybody in the division
who's going to be coming up challenging
so yeah i do weigh them up quite quickly
within a round or so
i know what to do with them can you
remember the point in your boxing career
especially when you were younger where
you thought
yeah i'm going to be the champ was there
a can you remember a moment that that
came in your head
yeah when i first put a pair of boxing
gloves on
i didn't come into boxing to be a boxer
yeah i didn't come into boxing to
to be a national champion or whatever i
come into boxing to be an heavyweight
champion of the world or nothing
that was my attitude from the first
amateur boxing fight i ever had
i was going to be everywhere champion of
the world was no doubt
i always believed it was it dad helpful
in actually instilling that belief since
he called it so early
was was that put into your head as well
by other people or
no no it wasn't put into my head it was
all like i believed it i wanted to me
dad told us not to box
he didn't want us boxing but i i wanted
to go boxing i wanted to go to the gym i
used to jog to the gym ride the bike to
the gym run home
all that sort of stuff didn't take me
there or whatever i was never forced to
go to the gym
i always just went there on my own
accord and i believe that's the best way
because
if you want it more than your son wants
it as you see with a lot of others today
they push their kids into doing
something that they want to do
yeah and if the if the child doesn't
want to do it
then you're wasting your time because
it's going to come to a point where
break point where they don't want to do
and this walk away from it
and that's what it was for me like i see
a lot of people
pushing the kids towards boxing or
whatever but you've got to really want
it more than anybody else
and i was the first person in the gym
the last person to leave
every day and there was nothing i wanted
more than to become overweight champion
of the world
and i trained hard i dedicated
sacrificed my life for it and it
happened
so i probably was one of the lucky ones
but when i think about it
going back to it was all meant to be you
can only be
and achieve things like that if you're
able and bodily well
and if your eyesight's good and you've
not got any problems
with your health and you know all these
things have to be
in order as well to allow you to do it
so i was
probably lucky that i was born with all
the right
faculties in order to enable me to to be
a boxer so yeah it all
it all fitted in like a jigsaw puzzle to
bit together it's been a long hard work
there's been a lot of people put a lot
of time in
you know it hasn't been me on my own
i've had a lot of input from other
people other boxing trainers
um it's been it's been a long long
process
i was i won't say millions of hours it's
been
of practice in the same stuff day in day
out and until you practice it that much
you can do it with your eyes closed
i've already got a few questions
definitely because i know we're against
the clock i don't want to keep you too
long
how long have we been here now it's been
a little while um all good podcasts go
on for ages though you know that
i mean no we've done a few you couldn't
do a ten minute one it'd be [__]
exactly i mean tell the guardian um the
longer the
podcast goes the more viewers happen the
longer the video
i'm happy to keep going for a load but i
would just do another two hours if you
want yeah exactly yeah all right she's
she's told me actually she told me we've
gotta go let you see it you gotta say
yes to women so i'm keeping to what she
said
sure um so when does boxing end for you
in your head how do you see the final
fight
the final when you say in that on that
microphone this is it for me can you
imagine that
no i'm not there yet mentally i'm not
there yet
i don't know how it ends i don't know
where it ends i've got three more fights
left
and then i'm i'm finished you're very
young still for a heavy weight as well
there's
one but i've been i've been turned pro
at 20. don't forget yeah a lot of these
guys don't tell pro till 26 27 30 year
old
so i've had a lot a long time in it so
you've got the males on the clock
um 11 years as a professional
heavyweight it's a long time
you've got to make space for your music
career as well yeah yeah
one of the other questions i do like to
ask people is if your life was turned
into a movie i guess this could be a
movie it'd be fair this book
um you know like in rocky where there's
a halfway point where he's like
not today like in something to the
turning point of his whole life
what is the turning point of your life
i'd probably say
was the moment i walked into a boxing
club because
without that day happening if i were to
went with my dad to the shop
instead of going to the steve egan's
boxing academy
then maybe i won't be the boxer i am
today i won't be here maybe i'll be
living a different life
and maybe i i've i can't imagine living
a different life and not being the
person i am
but obviously it was a very high
possibility that could have happened
so yeah i think the turning point for me
was entering a box engine for the first
time
my going to my local amateur boxing club
and and putting in the work and the
dedication
because it all stemmed from there
everything stemmed from there and it
wouldn't be possible
without that and a lot of people like to
take credit for what what's happened in
my career there's been a lot of boxing
trainers and
a lot of people but one money never
really gets enough credit and that's
steve egan
he was my first ever amateur boxing
trainer and we put in
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours and years
from 14 to 20. that's in this book yeah
of of training five six days a week
was that the foundation of you 100
we're putting a lot of time a lot of
time and when i wasn't the gypsy king
when i never had that rolls royce when i
never had no money when i couldn't
afford a bag of chips on the way home
you know steve saw a young kid who put a
lot of time into him
and i'm very thankful to him that's why
i put him in that book while i give him
a good
good uh write-up and put his good
picture in with him because he does
deserve a lot of credit and
without stevie i wouldn't i wouldn't be
on this um journey that i'm on that's
for sure
sometimes you need a mentor i guess
every great boxer has one
yeah and he he he always believed in me
from being from being 14
he said i'd be every week champion of
the world
so yeah that had a lot that gave me a
lot of belief yeah as well you know what
i mean
as along with me family and friends and
everybody else
but yeah he was the first like stranger
to believe in me that makes sense you
talk about people taking credit
i know this might sound like a silly
question but are you proud of yourself
because you know you talk about not
feeling fulfilled when you've had these
goals
people like you sometimes they're not
proud of themselves deep down enough is
what they should be do you feel proud of
yourself
i think proud is not one of my things
that i
i have pride
but i've definitely achieved everything
i wanted to do
and i'm definitely happy with i've never
boxed again i'm happy with what i've
done
and it was great when i beat klitschko
that was the everest for me it doesn't
get any better never will get any better
than that
beat him wild or beating anybody him
never beat
november 28th 2015. that was the be all
and all of my boxing career that was
when it was about boxing
when it was about achieving my dreams
and all that this second career has been
more fun
it hasn't been about boxing it's been
it's been a fun it's been a laugh
we've had a good time and the comeback
losing the weight
it's been it's been a fairy tale story
to come back it's been like
we've had banter we've had fun it's not
really been serious it's been
fun and games and i believe it's been a
it's been it's been nice
rather than all the hard times and all
the hardship and
everything that went on in my life and
all the ups and downs the second career
has been
it's been fun and i've really enjoyed it
it's been it's been probably the best
best part of it all because there was no
pressure it wasn't about becoming world
champions and winning all it wasn't
about winning or losing it wasn't about
homer going to fight the struggle was
over
i was boxing now for me i wasn't boxing
for history i wasn't boxing for a belt i
wasn't boxing to become wealthy or
wasn't boxing for fame or anything else
i was boxing for my happiness
that's when you're in your most best
place so
yeah that's been another turning point
for me coming back and enjoying my life
in korea
and i believe without that breakdown i
wouldn't have found this happiness that
i found today true happiness
breakdowns breakthrough yep yes exactly
um well i've only got one last question
fire away boss how would you like to be
remembered
and i get that asked question asked a
lot and i'm going to give exactly the
same
answer as i always do very short and
sweet
not interested
when you're being remembered it means
you're done and you're finished
and i ain't mentally ready for that yet
oh fantastic that's fantastic great
great thank you very much
for this interview i really appreciate
it very much it's been good it's been
it's been a great podcast really nice
just to chat to you and
yeah for over an hour if anyone wants to
get this i'm sure it'll be in shops
everywhere on
amazon i'm sure you're going to see that
big mouth for the beard every
supermarket you go in
i like this this back picture as well
fantastic that was when i got up in
round
nine or twelve and i shouted at him come
on love it
love it we were watching that weren't we
that was good that was the turning point
in the fight
yeah if you haven't already hit the like
button subscribe to the true jordan
youtube channel thanks for watching and
we'll see you later
thanks very much great podcast man thank
you very much